[Music]
why are there exactly 435 members of the
house of representatives it's not set by
the constitution but the permanent
apportionment act of 1929.
back then there were fewer than 250 000
people per district today there are
nearly three quarters of a million so
it's fair to ask just how representative
the house of representatives actually is
james madison the father of the
constitution would be dubious the house
was to be where the representatives of
america in all its diversity would come
together but can one person really speak
for 750 000 today's average district is
larger than any state back when the
constitution was ratified
so what can we do about that
madison might suggest increase the size
of the house
in federalist 56 he uses the british
house of commons as a model for the size
of the house
today the commons has 650 seats and
works reasonably well so maybe we could
add 200 more seats to the house without
undermining its ability to legislate
that would make our house and our
government more representative
to learn more about my new book james
madison america's first politician check
out the link in the description
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei